hey guys how's it goin on Michael aka
the bearded nun and I'm mark okay mark
have you seen the new Wonder Woman
design I have and I don't like it I like
to stamp it it's - its covers too much
up the good news to all of you is that I
have come up with my own concept art for
what I think what a woman should look
like ooh it's the sexiest most revealing
hottest ever all right I've actually got
a photo okay you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
and the of it all right look mark now
that I can be serious with you guys
subscribe to Vsauce it's daily video
game comedy we've got awesome people
working with it we've got commentaries
tutorials mashups music it's gonna be
covered in awesome sauce you're gonna
dress up like us female superhero
next week on thinking Catwoman more like
bad woman
[Music]